[Musique]
la légende dit qu'un beau jour un
nouveau reviendra et qu'il se servira du
pouvoir du trident
pour reconstruire l'atlantide
c'est ici que vulco m'a donné ma
première leçon de natation je sais nager
j'ai pas besoin d'apprendre
tu es bien loin du compte il ne faut
oublier tout l'enseignement du monde de
la surface à autre et font de toi même à
la découverte de désastre d'atlante
il a passé toute sa vie à s'entraîner
pour devenir le meilleur
mes parents ont fait de moi ce que je
suis
[Musique]
je suis le protecteur des profondeurs
en se bridant repose la force de
l'atlantique
en mauvaises mains il ne causerait
qu'une destruction meizu mains du vrai
héritier qui lui nierait terre et mer
l'heure est venue pour l'atlantide de
renaître à doit une fois l'arrêté à tout
prix que c'est quoi ton plan gianni pour
ça tu dois trouver ceux ci j'en ai déjà
assez bon
il est loin de valoir celui la guerre a
ravagé la surface que cela t'a gré ou
non
[Musique]
la mer le savais que tu étais
exceptionnel
elle était convaincue
ce serait toile unificateur de nos deux
mondes
l'atlantique 2 toujours eu un roi
aujourd'hui il faut plus
[Musique]
mais mieux qu'un roi ça serait quoi
un héros
[Musique]